did you experience
any i know you said the most powerful
weapon you have is your tongue because
if you say something it could
hurt three generations not just yourself
your parents your grandparents etc etc
but you know there has to be an element
of somebody being rebellious
and if there was somebody that was
rebellious if you do remember
what typically happened to somebody that
was rebellious against a regime like
that
so like in school right at
school i didn't go to school i didn't
learn about the revolution or democracy
or none of that
things that i learned is like how brave
like what kind of miracles our dear
leader can do
and how bad the west democracy the
the world was and you know everything
was brainwashing in school like even
like learning math
was like there are four american
ambassadors
you killed two of them then how many
american pastors
left to care as like five sixty years
old you say
two american bastards and the game that
you play
we don't play with the barbie doors we
don't play some legos
we play with tanks you either use
mud and build tanks and say the teacher
is like why did you build this tank
cause like
i will this thing because i wanna kill
our enemies
and be loyal to our dear leader and like
we build this snowman in school and we
bring like hot boiling water and pour on
top of the snowman
and that snowman we makes like american
monster
and you say hey american enemies are
gone so that's the education
so there was really no concept of being
a distant or being a rebellious
but i'm sure there was that's why you
see constantly see these public
executions
and see this political prison camp
people in our neighborhoods
disappear all the time and we always
have to go to see public you know
trier and public execution in north
korea there is no such a thing called
the concept of minor
even you are like five seven years old
if the
school teachers say you have to go see
public execution
when someone gets shot in front of your
high eyes
even kids have to go see the public
execution
and so in that situation i think
i think in some our ways we work
rebellious
like watching photon dvds
and that kills us but people still
risking their lives
imagine like right now we are risking
our life or watching or some kind of
movie any north korea people
actually literally risking their lives
to watch
a movie from the free world